the war in ukraine is shaping a new
global order as the fighting escalates
global powers are said to be considering
their future options but what will the
foundations of this new order be
and will western values still prevail
this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm nick clark the new war in europe has
been described as a turning point in
human history comparable to the attacks
of 9 11 or indeed the fall of the berlin
wall it's been more than a month since
russia invaded ukraine causing death and
destruction across much of the country
the invasion and the political disputes
around it are disrupting the global
order which have been in place since the
end of the cold war the conflict is also
defining how democracies will confront
future threats and conflicts western
powers view the invasion not just as an
assault on ukraine's sovereignty but in
the words of the uk foreign secretary
liz truss an assault on the foundations
and rules by which societies coexist
while the united states and its allies
want to bar russia from one of the
world's most important economic blocks
the g20 its members represent 85 percent
of global output 75
of international trade and two-thirds of
the world's population china says the
g20 is a forum to discuss economic
issues and is rejecting suggestions that
moscow could be barred because of its
invasion of ukraine
spoke at the doha forum on saturday and
in his remarks he addressed the need to
find peaceful solutions to global
conflicts
it is sorrowful to see a contraction in
the political and diplomatic means in
favor of military expansion and armed
solutions the militarization of
solutions has been growing for the last
four decades until it reached one of its
most challenging peaks in the ukrainian
war
from here i emphasised the firm position
of the state of qatar on the
renunciation of violence intimidating
civilians and assaulting state
sovereignty and all other acts that may
constitute a violation of human values
and international law we stand in
solidarity with millions of innocent
people and refugees who've been
victimized by this unjust war in
geopolitical calculations
as for china well it could stand to win
further influence in economic dominance
while the west maintains its pressure on
russia but now beijing seems to be
backing diplomatic efforts the chinese
foreign ministry says ukraine has asked
for help in finding a peaceful solution
meanwhile beijing's economy is being
hurt by rising commodity prices as a
result of the war
[Music]
all right let's bring in our guests in
new haven in connecticut we have nizam
asari who's a visiting professor at yale
university in oslo glenn diesen who's a
professor of international relations at
the university of south eastern norway
and in nottingham in the uk steve sang
who's director of the china institute at
sowers university of london a gentleman
a warm welcome to you all and steve sang
i'd like to start with you uh we look
back don't we at the years leading to
the first world war and wonder how it
was possible that they
didn't know the direction in which they
were heading is that how history do you
think will view this moment in time as
this earthquake rumbles under the
current world order
i think we have better recognition of
the importance of the russian invasion
of ukraine
this is one of those events in history
which is going to leave a major mark i
think we're looking at a
fall of berlin war in reverse kind of
moment here and i think there's
recognition of that
and glenn diesen do you think it's now
inevitable that the international order
will reposition itself
i think uh most definitely
not just international order but in
europe as well keep in mind that for the
past 30 years we kind of tried to figure
out what to do with europe because we
never really eliminated the dividing
lines in europe but now this will be
re-militarized that's during the cold
war and economies between europe and
russia
also need the couple so i think that uh
also globalization as we've known it is
now officially over uh i think
especially
uh some of it's because of the sanctions
against russia as well i mean after the
west seized the money from the russian
central bank this after doing similar
seizing similar money from afghanistan
iran venezuela i think that the world is
becoming much more skeptical of both the
dollar and the euro so i think the
russians of course they no longer want
to trade in
dollars or euros and we see that the
rest of the world are kind of responding
to this the indians are now wanting to
buy energy in rupees the saudis are now
considering to sell their energy in the
chinese also
in their ones and also instead of
sanctioning russia we see countries like
china
stating that they're willing to work now
to establish some kind of a parallel
economic financial infrastructure that's
not vulnerable to western sanctions so i
think this is definitely
a huge shift in international system it
also displays how the west or nato
and the rest of the world aren't
necessarily on the same page all right
we'll get into the wires and wherefores
of all of that in just a moment but
these are first of all news i'm sorry do
you think we were inexorably leading
uh to this moment
we had a series of events going back to
the twin towers in 911 to the financial
meltdown in 2008 to brexit to trump and
now this do you think it's been a
gradual progression that's been building
up to this moment
the gradual progression uh
is
depends on the focus we give it i think
that this is there is this focus you're
giving it but i think that there is
another focus the growth of china
and
the the pivot to the pacific and there
is so what i notice in today's uh
news and in today's analysis is that
people who are reminiscent from the cold
war are reviving
the
the tensions and
the hecticness of the years of the cold
war and bringing russia as the main
focus of international relations whereas
if we look at uh from the a broader
picture
the the shift is definitely towards the
the pacific the shift is towards a
competition between
a west led by uh by the us and uh
and china and its allies so i see here
russia more as
a satellite but not just a small
satellite but an important satellite but
more as a satellite
of china than really the main player and
that amazed at how many analyses are
focusing on on russia as if the main
topic is uh is russia so
uh and
and i think that's the the and the
second point i want to make is that if
we keep for when we keep focusing our
attentions in international relations to
uh relations among states we forget that
some people are paying the price and
it's individuals it's communities that
are really really paying the high price
of this
shift in power so it's the
ukrainians themselves but it's the
people
in around the world who are
who with the energy
prices uh going up with the
uh wheat uh going
wheat prices going up and this is
provoking a lot of concern among a lot
of people in the world not only about
ukraine but about the survival of
individuals uh on top of the the refugee
crisis so we need to bring our attention
not only to focus our attention not only
on state-to-state relations but also on
the impact of these on real people
really
so you mean
individuals in the sense of you know
rising commodity prices and so forth do
you
rising commodity prices the the refugee
crisis the tremendous refugee crisis
that the ukrainians are living today but
that the syrians lived that the yemenis
are still going through and
the afghan the afghans went through and
are still going through it so there are
tremendous refugee crisis around the
world
on top of the the commodity crisis that
you mentioned
er the german chancellor olaf schultz he
said that we're at a turning point and
it could lead in any different direction
uh steve sanger which the path do you
foresee it going down do you
agree with the view that china could be
the big strategic winner out of all of
this
i don't know whether china is going to
the big strategic winner out of this
um
but china is
a really big player in the picture
uh or at the moment slightly our focus
but it is good becomes the focus of
attention as the war in ukraine settled
down
at the moment with the war unfolding and
the certain future uncertain there is a
lot of
thinking about the end game being
focused on what will happen to ukraine
and to russia but as the war entrenches
itself and drags on there will be much
more attention being staged to the wider
contextualized idea of an end game which
is
what do
so-called the west
wants to see the world move forward
a very important parallel between russia
and ukraine
putin's view of ukraine in terms of
history and china and taiwan and xi
jinping's equally delusional view of
taiwan is that
we know perhaps 10 15 years down the
line china will invade taiwan
what will the west do i think that is
going to be much more the focus in the
next few years moving forward and when
that stay in focus
the whole
um
engagement
of the world order will change i don't
think we're going to see a return to the
old cold war but we are going to see a
new kind a new version of the
bifurcation of the world the chinese
government doesn't actually want that
and that's why i start off by saying i'm
not really sure the chinese end up being
the winner right so when you say that
that nations will be looking ahead to
this what you say is an inevitable uh
invasion of taiwan by china
uh
they will prepare for that moment by
continuing this decoupling of the west
from china is that what you mean
yes in general terms because at the
moment
the west i mean here the west means not
just europe and north america the
democracies more
generally can sanction russia
in the way that we have done
at a course that is significant but
tolerable to us
in the same situation
between taiwan and china we cannot
afford to do what we are doing to russia
to china our economy will suffer much
too much of the damage so there will be
recalibrating of what would be a safe
level of economic engagement with china
and the chinese government has
long had a policy of decoupling from the
west it goes all the way back to 2013
when xi jinping issues document number
nine which was essentially an internal
document declaring how china should be
very selectively decoupling from the
west
okay so
glenn the it's certainly true isn't it
that the world could not apply sanctions
on china in the way that it has with
russia because it relies on its trade
far too much just to keep the world
turning
uh definitely so obviously a complete
decoupling from china would not be
possible it would simply
destroy the global economy however that
being said you do have the issue of
certain degrees for example uh the the
question is not only of decoupling it's
having a favorable symmetry that means
from the u.s perspective they would like
to see themselves and europeans be less
dependent on china but china should be
more dependent on the west so in other
words skew the symmetry of dependence
now
but you can do this to certain degrees
and again from the united states
perspective for many years now they've
been attempting to instill some uh block
discipline uh to make to prevent
europeans from buying russian energy
buying chinese technologies and instead
only link themselves to the united
states and uh and obviously this is
possible to some extent and i think this
is also why the u.s now is trying to go
after china to some extent they're
claiming that they're supporting russia
and invasion of ukraine in order because
europeans have completely jumped on the
us bandwagon in terms of putting these
harsh sanctions against russia
to the extent that it's uh creating a
havoc for european economists however by
attempting to also blame and shift blame
towards the chinese i think the us also
would like to use this crisis as a way
of
of having the europeans also decouple a
little bit from from the from the
chinese again this is
been one of the key problems of the
united states they have the europeans i
mean have always had security dependence
on the us but they've had a very hard
time to convert the security dependence
into economic loyalty but now with this
heightened security threats we see the
u.s obviously has more uh
more influence over the europeans so
they will definitely exploit this crisis
to to the extent that
they can get europeans from not only cut
off from the russians but obviously also
the chinese but not completely obviously
because that's
not possible sure and and these are so
so we say that this is the end of
globalization that the world will
will now divide into separate
potentially hostile camps regardless
of what happens in ukraine
um
yes and no because i would
like to call our attention to the facts
that
many of the countries that
either didn't vote or abstain in the
general assembly or the resolution right
than in the invasion
and they they represent a significant
proportion of the world's population
right
well significant part of the world
population but it was also a significant
number of countries from the african
continent and from asia and those
countries that somehow coincidentally
were part of
1956 and uh and bandung so these
countries are saying look these are two
big dogs fighting and what is in it for
us
in this fight so this is not our fight
we have other issues we have other
demands and so this is this is going to
redefine uh word politics and these
countries will have somehow to choose
sides uh even during even during the
cold war and were at the height of the
third world uh
the non-aligned movement uh
many of those countries were siding
slightly with one spell or the other but
they were they had another argument they
were saying we our our
fight is another one and our issues are
different and i think that these same
countries are saying the same thing when
they are
thinking the same thing where they're
looking at this uh fight between these
two big dogs under us leadership and
currently under russian leadership but
it's uh russia china um
two challenging powers challenging the
status quo power of the united states so
this is what most of the world is seeing
i think and these are is it necessarily
a bad thing that the world order is
reshaped
not a bad thing but there were good
things in the in the post um
cold war order the
the the the norms and the values imposed
by the west with
the advance of democracy and
human rights and the protection of
minorities all of these things are very
important very valuable
and people from the social forum in
porto alegre that were protesting
against davos they were they wanted
globalization but the globalization of
these norms and these values for
protecting minorities and human rights
and democracy the advance of democracy
and its values and freedom of speech and
freedom of faith so those were very
positive values that a lot of people
will miss if they have to choose camps
and they have to choose sides and there
is a side that is
more authoritarian and more uh unwilling
to be
uh observing human rights and
the rights of minorities so that is a
negative point in this uh
change that will happen inevitably very
soon
glenn is it possible that some good will
come out of this that there's an
opportunity in fact here to to create a
a more united more
interconnected and perhaps more
sustainable
uh trading world i think so because well
we have to see that this is kind of
transition from the unipolar to a
multi-polar world so after the
aft after the cold war there was only
one center of power which was the united
states and uh organized around the
collective west now the west has been in
relative decline for for the past 30
years in terms of other centers of power
coming up but the u.s has never really
been able to let go of its key security
strategy which is
a global hegemony so the question was
always how would the multipolar system
come into place would it be through
negotiated settlements uh or would it be
through
conflict through war and
this is uh also well the crisis in
ukraine has kind of been a question of
this as uh as well
how would we transition would we find a
way to live on the same continent as the
russians and it turned out no and i
think the same applies to other centers
of the world but i think
i think some positive can possibly come
out of this because i don't see the
world
switching into hostile camps i think
with the decline of the u.s hegemon i
think there's more uh
this this becomes less zero-sum game
perhaps around the world and as we see
these are not all conflicting camps and
again despite all this talk about you
about russia being isolated in the world
the reality is pretty much there's only
the nato countries plus japan australia
who has put sanctions on russia so if we
see the chinese indians and well the
rest of the world they don't really they
obviously they don't support the russian
invasion as this is an illegal war
violation of international laws they
haven't picked russia's side but also
they don't uh they don't um
they see this largely as a nato-russia
proxy war in ukraine so so they don't
want to pick any sides and obviously
most of the world i would assume also
don't really see any moral authority on
the side of nato after all of our wars
through this
past decades with the hundreds of
thousands of dead so i think that the
world is
will start to organize more into the
different polls of power and
once this uh and this could have a
beneficial impact on this zero-sum game
which tend to play right let me put the
same question to steve do you think
there could be a positive result out of
all this misery
in principle there could always be
but in reality i think the world has
become a much more dangerous place
and the direction of travel
that the world was owned has been
changed
i think
it's easy to simply look at the polls
cold war
era as a time where it was about
americans dominance
i think we should really see it in a
much wider context it was also an era
when the european union was
changing or for at least until now
changing the way how we look at
ourselves and our relationship with
other nations
the idea that in europe
a war like what we are seeing in ukraine
today
could not happen
it was wonderful while it last it was an
idea
that until the invasion
was having effect
beyond europe
to spread the idea that the world needs
to move on and cannot stay
in the mindset of the 19th or the 20th
century now in the end
this is more idealistic going beyond
nationalism aspirations of the european
union
has been burst as a bubble by the
russian invasion
and this i think has changed the world
and we are drifting into a bifurcated
world whether
we like it or not and whether the
chinese like it or not they don't they
want to have a united world where china
ultimately
will becomes the dominant power but
that's not going to happen
right and let me let me just move it on
steve sorry to jump in because we're
just coming towards the end of the
program i just want to bring in nizar
one last time
i mean i hate to end on a on a you know
bad note but
it steve's right isn't he because
stability between great powers depends
on reaching some kind of mutual
agreement to maintain the status quo and
that clearly moving forwards at least in
the
near to middle term is going to be
impossible with russia isn't it
it is going to be difficult because the
the rising power china is going to
challenge
more and more the united states
and the order it's established after the
end of the cold war so this is the
moment of this shifting end of this
negotiation
but
we are not going to see immediate uh uh
an immediate clash of military might
between these two superpowers but
it might eventually come a little bit
later uh just one caveat towards the the
last statement i think that europe went
through a period of peace
after the end of the cold war but during
that period of peace we had the war
there was in bosnia the war in
kosovo we had
georgia we had the first invasion of
ukraine and
crimea so this period was not that
peaceful and that's calm in europe
either so
that was the only uh
slight disagreement i wanted to sure all
right we'll have to leave it there
thanks very much indeed gentlemen for
joining us today nizam asadi glenn
diesen and steve sang thanks very much
indeed for joining us for this
interesting discussion and thank you too
for watching you can see this program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com and indeed for further
discussion just go to our facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash aj
inside story and you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from mainland clark the
entire team here in doha it's goodbye
for now
you